[Music]
all right today's question comes from
christina in houston christina writes my
younger sister is 23 and works a
part-time job at a mall
she's a college dropout refuses to get a
full-time job and has a different dream
job every day that she won't take any
action on she lives with our parents
pays no bills and has maxed out credit
cards when i mention getting a full-time
job while creating an action plan for
her current dream she says there's no
time to work a full-time job cook work
out hang out with her boyfriend and do
these small steps towards her dream
she has good intentions but often gets
crippled at the overwhelming thought of
juggling everything
my parents tend to be enablers because
they don't want to make her mad and
pushing her in the wrong direction
how can i help her have the life that
she
wants
who unfortunately older sister i don't
believe can because she continues your
younger sister continues to have parents
that are funding and supporting and
enabling this life
reminds me of our friend
henry cloud says sounds like she needs
to get some problems she needs to get
some challenges she doesn't have enough
problems her parents need to have her
out she doesn't have any bills she
doesn't have any she is not dealing with
reality here how can you help her have
the life she wants talk your parents
into kicking her out that's right
setting some boundaries or you start
paying rent in four months and this is
what that's going to look like yeah
because this girl is operating on a 13
year old
emotional level that's not a 23 year old
emotional level
she's a little girl that wants to do
whatever she wants and she's got
princess itis and mama needs to kick her
out listen baby
an eagle that doesn't leave the nest is
eventually known as a turkey
it's a problem
that may be the most tennessee thing
i've ever heard you say
well i mean i like it though i like it
yeah you gotta go man you gotta you
gotta fly you do not emotionally develop
the final steps of your emotional
development into adulthood while living
under your parents roof that's right not
in america
now there's other cultures where that's
more standardized and there's a
different process but the typical anglo
american
idea and it's not to be cold and it's
not to be mean or it's not to be any of
that but you just when you pay your own
light bill when there's no milk in the
refrigerator unless you get your butt up
off the couch go to the grocery store
and buy some milk with your money and
put it in the refrigerator something
happens to you developmentally it's
called responsibility and moms and dads
if you do not instill this in your kids
you are stealing from them you are
robbing from your kids if you don't
encourage them not encourage them
through well you know it'd be good but
require them to have responsibilities to
do hard things to get jobs to
participate around the of the function
of your home
it gives them strength
to go do life
it's amazing how often that doesn't
happen we took our first kid to college
um
we spent the whole day moving her in
and um it was a two and a half hour
drive
and uh of course it's my oldest and it's
my daughter
and so we cried
almost halfway home about an hour 15
minutes yeah
and by the time we got here the sun had
come out we were smiling life is good we
took the second one to college rachel um
dropped her off in the dorm we cried
one exit
nothing a dairy queen couldn't fix and
then we got to the third one and we said
college is that way
exactly
and we just helped him pack the truck
and he left that's right
have a great weekend man so because uh
we were looking forward to empty nesting
your mom and dad christina need to look
forward to empty nesting
[Laughter]
we love it
it's awesome
yeah so um
yeah it's the natural evolution of life
and it is a
that
my point of telling that story on myself
is to tell you the truth the truth is
that change
from raising kids to releasing them is a
painful change it's brutal it's hard
brutal and your mom and dad are being
wusses
by not turning
your dog your little sister is their
security blanket they don't want to face
their life when she's gone
and so and they're they're they're
couching all of this and being nice to
her and that's absolute bull they're
selfish they need to release her that
that that may be the best word they're
selfish like they are choosing their
momentary
um she's their security blind that's
right she's a the little [ __ ] i don't
want this to be over right that's it and
it's not over it's just it's different
that's right it's just different yeah
and so and let me tell you the different
part is if she gets out there and
marries the boyfriend has babies that's
the awesome part so let's do it yeah
grandbabies i mean they're awesome i
don't know how great grandbabies are
going to be out have been nicer to their
parents
so i mean it's just you know
you you there's a lot of that a lot of
stuff going on here so bottom line is
christina you really can't help her
john's right the only thing the biggest
help you could do is talk your parents
into releasing her
if you could convince your parents that
they're harming her
not blessing her which is actually the
truth then you probably have done your
job for the day